hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
salamander Sally flopping around here
today
we're gonna do it try not to laugh
challenge what could go wrong best funny
moments in fails 2019
my good buddy Tyrone Magnus made this a
try not to laugh and I heard that this
video we'd better suited for a reaction
if we made it a try not to laugh so I'm
like all right Sally is terrible at
these she's good at very few things in
her life and that's a laugh is not one
of them let's do this doing that workout
right
well
I know he's gonna fall straight onto the
camera isn't he
No oh my god no no
[Music]
why would I laugh with it that is so
cool Oh No
[Music]
Oh No
young-min my toilet why would you do the
pinata such closed spaces
Oh broken live performance
[Music]
that's usually korangal
[Music]
whoa that's like a [ __ ]
no we all can feel that yeah did he lose
this vote right here do you get it don't
you are buddy
[Music]
this is an hour long right here is he
[Laughter]
[Music]
you plot a gun I thought I thought
people broke into me for letting them
rims no terrible oh did she cut her hand
a word
awesome that's amazing
that's amazing
he's slit in there oh oh she's a bully
so I want him to want to fight him on
the sidelines
[Music]
I just realized what he was doing guys
are bombing if you're right just while
you can't wait stop this board is
borderline
[Laughter]
oh he's smart he ready to light up
[Music]
oh it's so stupid
kind of cool butts stupid
still going why why
if he's not preparing for a movie role
that I don't know what he's doing
it's genuinely how that happened that's
so dear toilet humor that's happening
[Music]
still kinder
hey for the most part that was pretty
whoa
why did you even
oh he's in a bad mood no oh no oh no oh
no this is great that was a great
compilation right there some of them
aren't that funny this one like the
whole way through thank you oh yeah
every one of these was really
entertained the ones that were the
funniest are the ones that are the most
relatable like the one with the butter
letters the kid who's like sitting
around in a dress and walking about but
in that like dizzy position before there
was another one though oh the one we all
can relate to like troubling situations
when our bones break yeah I was once on
a ride at a carnival we were upside down
and I watched my phone just fall out of
my pocket no way
actually there's the one where the guy
had a surprise party that reminded me of
something I did to my dad when I was a
teenager
and my dad was like a six-foot four he's
really tall guy big guy too big one time
I decided or scary kind of what happens
to a punch line ha this what happened at
the end Greg you are now ruin the story
for him what happened was I jumped in
front of him and he didn't punch me he
did something different he had just been
taking karate lessons away so he had
this position where he would go like
this this fighting position and I'm a
kid so when I went Rob when he put
through the door he went like the
forearm hit right against my chest and I
wouldn't fly
yeah I was flying back in yeah so I try
not to do that to people unless this job
because that just makes me laugh
surprisingly yes especially for a guy
who's worked at Halloween or nights it's
really easy to get to him but yeah some
of these are just seems so painful yeah
[Music]
my guys and girls who get like
completely drenched wet I always feel
bad for them because I know most of them
have a phone in their pocket have you
ever jumped in water with a phone in
your pocket
it's a terrible healing I have not but I
have accidentally dropped my phone and
very interesting places like we had this
gutter with water coming down it but it
was perfectly sunny out and I just so
happened to like drop it in the water
and that was my mom my you gotta know
she talked about Carol I gave my mom my
phone because I didn't have a purse with
me and we put her in the stalls going to
the bed and then I've had my phone get
drenched in bubbles one time I had a
bubble gun in the same bag as my phone
and stabbed messed it up I've dropped it
down an elevator shaft and then somehow
got it out myself and it was at that one
it was fine all the other destroyed you
will never use my phone ever
I don't know how you get your photo
these unfortunate positions there was
one here that was genuinely awesome and
that was the spider-man that was so cool
it was one of the coolest things I've
ever seen happen new spider-man outfit
or not that would be like just so sweet
I thought he was gonna like follow the
trolley or something I was hoping that
that wouldn't happen
you stuck the landing that was awesome
what is this channel I want to watch
more videos from these guys let's shout
them out properly
am i tight oh as 10 K followers screw
that I'm hitting that notification valve
4 am i tight this was a great video
thank you guys for sending that over
here's how life works
Tyrone Magnus covers a lot of videos in
a given day every once in a while he
does something with like real rejects
you guys gotta check it out Tyrone did
it and this is one of those videos
alright guys well thanks for being here
you can subscribe to the reject nation
thanks for being here salamander Sally
with the Lomonaco of the Lomonaco the
laminating of the Loehmann's bye bye